so kanye west has said some things about
pete davidson god sent me from that
crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
he may be getting himself into a world
of legal trouble now unless you've been
living under a rock you probably have
some familiarity with the public
fighting between kim kardashian and her
ex and baby father kanye west now in the
aftermath of this bitter divorce fans
and observers have expressed concern
about kanye's increasingly erratic
public behavior against kim kardashian
his threats against people like
kardashian's new partner pete davidson
and feuds with comedians like trevor
noah who criticized west conduct so
today we're going to cover the laws of
harassment stalking and domestic
violence and analyzed to what extent
kanye's eccentric bluster crosses the
line into potential criminality and
addresses the legal measures that
kardashian and davidson could take to
protect themselves and their children as
well and what's going to happen to
kanye's kids in the aftermath of this
erratic behavior
[Music]
now even if you've never watched the
kardashians reality show the family's
forays into everything from music and
politics into popular culture have made
it increasingly difficult to not keep up
with the kardashians whether you wanted
to or not but if you managed to stay
uninformed about the kardashians for
this long
well too bad because we're going to
cover what in the world is going on now
here's a brief timeline of the kim yay
saga based on publicly available facts
now kim and kanye began dating in 2012
before they formally tie the knot in
2014. the couple shares four children
daughters north and chicago and sons
saint and psalm now as the years went by
west's struggles with mental health
began to spill into the public view and
in november 2016 one month after kim was
famously robbed at gunpoint at her hotel
in paris west triggered backlash and
confusion at his performances by going
on controversial rants about politics
and race and then ending shows early now
west abruptly cancelled his tour and was
immediately hospitalized for psychiatric
evaluation due to quote acting
erratically during which time he was
allegedly handcuffed in the back of an
ambulance for his own safety west
continued to generate negative publicity
for himself when he told tmz regarding
400 years of enslavement of african
americans quote that sounds like a
choice now he would admit in a 2018
interview with the new york times that
he feared that these comments to tmz
would cause his wife to leave him and if
that wasn't enough in july of 2020 the
music mogul took to twitter to announce
his candidacy for president of the
united states where he'd go on to earn
60 000 total votes as he missed the
ballot deadline by several weeks and
then weeks after that kardashian posted
a lengthy statement on instagram
addressing her then husband's erratic
posts and struggles with bipolar
disorder quote anyone who has bipolar
disorder or has a loved one in their
life who does knows how incredibly
complicated and painful it is to
understand i've never spoken publicly
about how this has affected us at home
because i'm very protective of our
children and kanye's right to privacy
when it comes to his health but today i
feel like i should comment on it because
of the stigma and misconception about
mental health the marriage however would
not last and kardashian formally filed
for divorce in february of 2021. in
december 2021 kardashian petitioned the
court to declare her quote legally
single and restore her maiden name
declaring their marriage quote uh
irredeemably broken down and no
counseling or reconciliation effort will
be of any value at this time kanye who
had just changed his name to just yay
opposed kardashian's motion to be
declared single arguing issues related
to custody of the children and shared
properties needed to be resolved now
replying to yi's motion kardashian told
the court quote i very much desire to be
divorced and that these social media
posts were rife with misinformation
regarding our private family matters and
co-parenting on social media which has
created emotional distress and on march
2nd 2022 kim's petition to be legally
single was granted the divorce grew even
more contentious when davidson and
kardashian reportedly started dating in
late fall 2021. on social media yay
would alternate between begging
kardashian to reconcile and attacking
her parenting style in since deleted
instagram posts yay expressed concern
for his daughter north appearing on
tiktok claimed that kardashian had
accused him of putting a hit out on her
and claimed kardashian was keeping his
children away from him kardashian fired
back yay for his constant attacks
against her and criticized his purported
quote obsession with trying to control
and manipulate the situation yay's
vitriol towards davidson also spilled
into public view in the form of a
rap-based attack in the song easy yea
raps god save me from that crash just so
i can beat pete davidson's ass
which doesn't actually rhyme but anyway
in one music video for the song the
claymation yay kidnaps beheads and
buries davidson in a follow-up video an
animated monkey beats up pete davidson
now in early march pete davidson's
friend david cyrus reported text
messages between yay and davidson in
which the snl star defends kardashian as
quote literally the best mother i've
ever met and confronts the rapper for
his months of harassing behavior on
social media against kardashian and
himself telling ya quote to grow the
[ __ ] up davidson reportedly informed yay
that he was in la for the day and
offered to meet privately to talk things
out when he asked for davidson's
location the king of staten island star
sent a photo of himself flashing a peace
sign with his fingers sticking out and
his tongue with the cheeky reply in bed
with your wife yay proposed meeting at
his sunday service but davidson refused
suggesting that yay was more interested
in publicity than resolution and
davidson offered to help yay with his
mental health reportedly telling the
rapper quote it's so sad to see you ruin
your legacy on the daily davidson wrote
let me help you man highlighting his own
struggles with mental health quote it's
not an easy journey you don't have to
feel this way anymore
there's no shame in having a little help
you'll be so happy and at peace
entertainers like billy eilish and dl
hughley began to weigh in on yay's
threatening behavior sparking their own
feuds with the rap mogul and in a daily
show segment trevor noah called out
yay's belligerent treatment of his
ex-wife describing the whole saga as
quote terrifying to watch that exemplify
the type of harassment that so many
women go through when they choose to
leave in response yay angrily attacked
the south african comedian on instagram
with racial slurs earning yay a 24-hour
ban for violating the site's policies on
hate speech bullying and harassment okay
so i think that means we're all caught
up now we can talk about the legal
implications of all of this erratic
behavior now in the face of these
threats against davidson and the
unstable behavior towards ms kardashian
some have advised them to get a
restraining order so what are the
options when it comes to protecting
themselves and the children when it
comes to a restraining order well let's
start with the basics a restraining
order also called a protective order is
a court order that can protect an
individual from being physically or
sexually abused threatened stalked or
harassed the person the restraining
order is against is called the
restrained person the person requesting
the restraining order is called the
protected person and restraining orders
can be broadened to include family or
other household members as part of that
class of protected persons as the name
suggests restraining order restrains the
third party from committing certain
actions against the protected persons
and then one type of restriction is a
personal conduct order which prohibits
the restrained party from any of the the
following actions including contacting
the person attacking stalking
threatening sexually assaulting
harassing destroying personal property
or disturbing the peace of those
protected people and a protected person
can also obtain what's called a stay
away order which is probably the kind of
restraining order you're familiar with
in the media where a restrained person
has to keep a certain distance away from
the protected person or where that
person lives their place of work the
children's school their vehicle and
other important places and if that
restrained person violates the
restraining order then they may be sent
to jail or pay a fine or both now
additionally a domestic violence
restraining order protects an individual
from abuse when the abused and the
abuser are or have been in an intimate
relationship and the abuse prohibited is
not limited to the actual infliction of
physical injury or committing assault as
psychological torment is also included
and if the parties haven't dated and
don't have a close relationship then
that falls under the purview of a civil
harassment restraining order since yay
and kardashian were married and have
children together kardashian might be
able to seek a domestic violence
restraining order while pete davidson
might be entitled to seek a civil
harassment order now just because yay's
outbursts have mostly played out on
social media doesn't make them any less
potentially alarming on the contrary
yay's escalation on social media is
typical if patterns that translate into
real world abuse so could ya's conduct
actually support a domestic violence
protective order from ms kardashian well
if kardashian shows that she has
actually suffered emotional distress or
fear of harm as a result of yay's
conduct and that fear is reasonable then
there's a decent chance a judge would
grant kardashian a restraining order and
here there are several things that
constitute abuse that would give rise to
an order but what's most relevant here
is that making someone reasonably afraid
that they or someone else are about to
be seriously hurt through threats or
promises to commit harm
would qualify as abuse that would rise
to the level of a restraining order and
under california law a credible threat
means intentionally saying something or
acting in a way that would make a
reasonable person afraid for his or her
safety or the safety of his or her
family an incredible threat to violence
includes following or stalking someone
making harassing calls sending harassing
messages by phone email mail or over a
period of time even if it's a short time
and a threat may be implied by a pattern
of conduct and need not be explicitly
stated now some have questioned whether
yay's repeated efforts to win back
kardashian even after she closed the
door on reconciliation constitutes
stalking in december 2021 yay purchased
the house across the street from his
soon-to-be ex-wife's house purportedly
so he could be closer to his kids now
during a charity event that same month
west while kardashian and their daughter
north was in attendance tweaked the
lyrics of a song to beg for his
estranged wife to return to him in
february 2022 yay shared a photo collage
of kardashian and their children where
he publicly pleaded with her to rekindle
their romance writing in a sense-deleted
post quote god please bring our family
back together so is this stalking or a
credible threat well this alone probably
not there are three common defenses to
stalking charges that one no credible
threat was made that there was no intent
to cause fear uh and or three that the
activities were constitutionally
protected now to date there's been no
indication that yay has made a credible
threat of violence against his ex or
their family or that his actions are
calculated to cause fear gae's efforts
to win back his ex on social media are
not coupled with
what would normally be considered
threats to her safety so they likely
fall under constitutionally protected
speech and while moving close to one's
ex can seem alarming this act alone is
not going to be enough to constitute
stalking so yay purchasing a house to be
closer to his kids is likely not
stalking in the absence of threats
though it's potentially possible that
yay's actions could fall under the
broader umbrella of harassment which
includes threats of violence that
seriously scare annoy or harass someone
and serves no legitimate purpose
and to constitute harassment the
offender must engage in a course of
conduct that would cause a reasonable
person to suffer substantial emotional
distress and must actually cause
substantial emotional distress to the
petitioner kardashian has already filed
a motion in her divorce case saying that
yay's social media posts were full of
quote misinformation regarding our
private family matters and co-parenting
on social media which has created
emotional distress and according to one
insider kim has grown particularly
disturbed by her ex when he alleged in a
mid-march instagram post that davidson
quote will hook her on drugs this
comment allegedly alarmed kardashian so
much that she hired security to protect
herself and davidson quote she's scared
and is so jumpy she is really on her
guard and making sure she has security
right now and has asked pete to also
take precautions now california law
allows parties to get a restraining
order against conduct that disturbs a
person's peace even in the absence of
violent threats and based on the
publicly available evidence it's
possible that kardashian has cause for a
domestic violence restraining order
against yi for harassment and disturbing
her peace but what about pete davidson
can he get a restraining order and is
rap music a criminal threat now if you
told me last year that i was going to
analyze rap music using claymation to
simulate murder whether that could
constitute a crime
honestly i probably wouldn't have
questioned it given how strange the last
few years have been but let's dive into
this thing and as i mentioned in yay's
song easy
one of the lyrics threatens to quote
beat pete davidson's ass and in the
first easy music video uh he beheads and
then buries a claymation pete davidson
and in the next video yay has an
animated davidson beaten up by a monkey
now in response to criticism yay wrote
on an instagram post that art is therapy
and denied that he was making threats
quote art is not a proxy for ill or harm
any suggestion otherwise about my art is
false and mal intended so did yay commit
a crime in his music videos by
threatening to beat up davidson while
attacking animated representations of
davidson and does pete davidson have any
grounds for civil harassment restraining
order against yay well davidson's public
statements that he's not afraid of yay
is probably not going to help his case
for threatening this as criminal conduct
furthermore the leaked text messages
between yay and davidson purport to show
davidson eager to meet yay in public to
talk things out which undermines a claim
that davidson feels stalked or harassed
or suffering from actionable sustained
fear and furthermore the first amendment
gives a lot of leeway to artists and
gives a broad right to depict
exaggerated violence against public
figures so long as they don't directly
declare their intention to actually hurt
another person or encourage others to do
so like when kathy griffin
controversially held a mock severed head
of then president trump it might have
been in poor taste
and knocked her from the coveted c-list
to d-list
but it probably broke no laws given
yay's denial that he intended to
threaten davidson and davidson's lack of
fear yay's musical mutilation is likely
not a crime now that being said there
could be some really severe consequences
for kanye at least concerning his
visitation rights and custody of his
children for restrained persons a
restraining order can have very serious
consequences particularly in the context
of domestic violence and if kardashian
successfully wins a domestic violence
restraining order against yay he could
lose custody of his young children and
even lose the right to be in their lives
entirely california law has special
rules for custody and visitation rights
when it comes to domestic violence and a
judge will treat your case as a domestic
violence matter if one a parent has been
convicted of domestic violence against
the other parent in the last five years
or two any court has decided that one
parent committed domestic violence
against another parent or the children
and in fact under california law a judge
cannot award custody joint or otherwise
to the parent who committed domestic
violence unless that abusive parent
meets the burden to show among other
things that custody is in the best
interest of the children the abusive
parent committed a 52-week batterer
intervention program and has completed
any court-ordered substance abuse
counseling or parenting class has
complied with any restraining orders and
has not committed any further domestic
violence if kardashian obtains a
domestic violence restraining order it's
possible though not incredibly likely
that yay could lose all right to custody
be subject to supervised visitation or
even be ordered to stay at least 100
yards away from his ex and their young
children yay can be ordered to stop
communicating with kardashian and
davidson both directly and indirectly
via social media and in fact the family
law judge handling divorce could order
yay to stop discussing the divorce his
kids and his ex-wife's new boyfriend
with the public if kardashian proves
that she feels threatened or harmed by
this conduct
you know throughout this entire ordeal
yay has maintained that he's always been
acting in the best interest of his
children but if yay doesn't get his act
together and stop with this bizarre and
potentially menacing behavior he risks
losing his family forever now with
situations like these it's always
important to avoid emotion and think
logically which you can learn to do with
today's sponsor brilliant brilliant is
an online learning platform for stem
that replaces lecture videos with
hands-on interactive lessons it's for
curious learners both young and old
professional and inexperienced so if
you'd like to exercise your brain or
help your kids with school brilliant has
you more than covered now one of my
favorite courses is all about logic
brilliance logic courses cover liar and
truth-teller riddles logical fallacies
machine logic and even some strategic
game theory and logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers need every day and
brilliant lets you learn by doing rather
than listening to hours of boring
lectures learning through doing is
scientifically proven to be the most
effective way to master any skill and
the courses have storytelling
interactive challenges and problems to
solve you will absolutely love it and
within brilliance library you'll find
courses like calculus linear algebra
math and that applies to trading and
finance basically every scientific and
mathematical thing that you would want
to learn you'll also find courses on
gravitational physics astronomy and
machine learning now you can sign up and
start learning for free today with the
link that's on screen right now which
will take you to brilliant.org
legaleagle and the first 200 people to
sign up will also get 20 off their
annual subscription so just click on the
link that's on screen right now or in
the description to get 20 off your
subscription to brilliant plus clicking
on that link really helps out this
channel and while you're there click on
this link to all my other real law
reviews for more legal news so click on
this link or i'll see you in court